I hate the taste of water,
so I always need to keep my liquid IV hydration multipliers on hand.
Obsessed with their new packaging
and their pear flavor has been my favorite one lately.
So naturally that inspired me to make one of my favorite things,
which is bread and pear jam.
I combined all of my ingredients in my stand mixer
and gave that a mix until it came together
before gradually adding in more flour.
Once it reached the consistency I wanted,
I transferred it over to a greased bowl
and let that rise until it doubled in size.
I cut my dough in half since I was making two loafs,
and rolled those pieces up to fit into my loaf pan,
then let that rise for another hour
while I got started on making my pear jam.
I like using different varieties of pears.
I just make sure that they're ripe.
Start by peeling them
and then wrapping them up in small pieces
before transferring them over to a bowl.
I have all my pears in a bowl.
I add some sugar and lemon juice.
Let that sit for about six hours.
You can also do it overnight.
Once my bread has risen,
I pop it in the oven for about 30 minutes until it's golden brown.
Once it's done,
I transfer it over to a wire rack to cool.
I decided on making a Rosemary and pear jam,
so I chopped up some Rosemary and added That to a pot with my pears
that boil for about 15 minutes.
And once it reached the temperature I wanted,
I transferred it over to a glass jar to cool.
While my jam was cooling,
I sliced up my bread and spread some butter on top.
Lastly added my jam.
And this was so good and so worth it.
There's nothing better to me than fresh bread and a cold
hydrating drink.